can i show you the symbol first of all
uh because uh that's kind of at the
center of it and i'm going to draw the
sort of the quick and dirty sequels
which looks like this
okay
uh and it's kind of a bit like an equal
sign but it's zigzaggy and the reason
for that is uh it's
a sort of a
approximation symbol
but it's more precise than that and the
zigzagginess uh and the zeds are
supposed to make you kind of think of
zeros because this technique involves
lots of zeros especially for big
calculations
really what we're doing is reducing
every number to one significant figure
and let's start with a really simple
calculation you know when your basic
times tables like three times seven well
hopefully everyone knows that that's 21
but actually if we say what it z equals
then
we round it to the nearest
round number with one digit followed by
a zero so three times seven is equals
twenty okay let's take another one so
five times eight
equals
bad example
yeah that's right let's do seven times
eight because no one can ever remember
that but i'll tell you what it equals it
equals 56
but it's equals
60 because you round it
ruthlessly to one significant figure
it's almost more work at the moment to
do the zeke when we eat this yeah i can
see why you'd think that but uh if we
get onto a more complicated calculation
i think you'll begin to see why it's
actually quite handy to just simplify
everything at the first opportunity
should we do a big one 436
times uh 68
okay well if we're z-equaling this the
first thing we do
is simplify these numbers so
that's z equals 400
times
70. okay so we've simplified both those
to make this calculation because then
it's just gonna be four times seven and
then add on all the zeros at the end so
that equals
well seven fours are 28 followed by
three zeros so it
equals 28
000. but actually we're being really
ruthless because we just want a rough
answer
it's equals
30 000. so 436 times 68 is equals 30
000. and you know what that's pretty
close to the right answer just check
what the actual answer is 29
648 now in this case that is really
close so z quartz has been amazingly
accurate it's not always quite as
accurate as that but in fact in most
estimation challenges you're really
looking for
something that's an order of magnitude
and and sequels works in most situations
hi there everyone i'm going to interrupt
my own video at this point because i can
hear some of the number files screaming
at the screen upset by this this
ruthless rounding this dismissing of
digits
and i can kind of understand that so i
spoke to my graphing expert dave wiley
told him about zeke
and he actually put this together this
is a graph showing where z equals is at
its strongest and also where it's
furthest from the true answer
i thought it might be worth a look and
i've put more details about it on my
blog i'll talk about this more at the
end of this video but let's get back to
hearing more about what rob has to say
about sequels i think the most valuable
thing here is it's giving you a feel for
numbers because you know there's a lot
of obsession these days with people need
to learn how to do long multiplication
and so on well we all use a calculator
for anything difficult these days and we
don't need
most of us most the time to do a really
accurate calculation a calculator can do
that for us
but we do need to have a feel for
numbers and i suspect that many people
who use calculators have no idea when
the answer comes out whether that number
is vaguely right or not and the great
power of of sequels is it just allows
you to very quickly work out roughly
what the answer is so you can say well
look is the number i've come up with
does it even make sense or has my i've
typed something wrong into this
calculator onto my
laptop or whatever so
what this is trying to generate more
than anything else is a feel for numbers
and the sort of the power to be able to
say you know what i don't know what
exactly the answer is but i do know
roughly what the answer is is this
something people do intuitively anyway i
think they do i i'm sure uh
i have been estimating for years i think
the difference here really between this
and any old estimation is just uh how uh
ruthlessly you're simplifying things to
one significant figure so when we did
the the tables you know 7 8 or 56 7 8 is
equals 60 uh most people don't think to
make the simplification at that point so
i'm just taking it one stage further to
become a bit of a
a rounding extremist
you can be even more extreme than zeke
equals incidentally you could round 60
and say we'll call it 100 it's close
enough uh but i'm i'm just a little bit
short of that extreme i would say i'm
not a sort of fifth decimal place kind
of person i really am as equalsy kind of
person i'm i'm uh you know as a degree i
actually did engineering and there it's
all about you know
having a feel for numbers there's a joke
goes about
how you can tell the difference between
an engineer and a mathematician so you
ask them what pie is and a mathematician
will say you know it's 3.14 and it goes
on forever a transcendental number
whereas an engineer will say well it's
about three but let's call it 10 just to
be on the safe side is this the thin end
of a wedge i sometimes think that the
emergence of text messaging and things
like that
has really eroded people's spelling
ability
would the emergence of sequels in a kind
of
lazy rounded estimation
take away some of the real skill and
craft that we want to
engender in our future mathematicians
i i would say completely the opposite if
only your typical 14 year old frankly
even could just say off the top of the
head what 7 8 is but it's 56 in the
first place let alone be able to then
round it to 60. so i think this skill is
missing
in so much of the population let's get
them to this stage and actually
strangely enough
i think the ability to estimate even
though it's all rough and ready
sometimes you actually need a lot of
maths understanding to be able to do it
in the first place it probably has its
most common application in financial
stuff working something out you know
you're in a shop you're working out a
deal and
i mean there's a question i've been
asking
teenagers quite interesting to ask you
say right i've got 70 people each one of
mars bar and let's say the mars bar cost
80 p and 70 people so how much is that
going to cost and how much we're going
to have to spend on that
and they kind of know it's seven eighths
maybe they know seven eight or 56 but
they'll probably say five pounds 60
because that sounds like about what
you'd spend on mars bars so people say
well hang on a sec you know 70 times 80
it's like kind of
50 times a hundred and what's that oh
five thousand fifty percent okay so so
it's sort of does this answer make sense
i can give you an example of when
sequels would perhaps not be a good idea
uh for example if you're taking your
child's temperature and you like to use
old-fashioned fahrenheit for that and
say well it's 98.4 let's z equals that
let's call it 100. well uh suddenly
you're thinking well maybe i should take
it to the doctor then knowing when it's
appropriate to round numbers and when
not is kind of i've rather hidden that
away in all of the sequel stuff that
that is a skill a life skill and
experience skill i hope they'll see the
point i hope they still see that i'm not
some you know ignorant person who's
imposing some impurity on this great
subject uh but actually this is a handy
tool i'm gonna guess quite a few of your
viewers actually kind of do this with
variations themselves you know so i'm
just offering one technique where it's a
shared language we all play the same
game we round to one figure
but i'm not saying it's the best i'm
just saying it's one that's got a name
now and a symbol
now rob's got a book out called more
maths for mums and dads the teenage
years and it's in that book he talks
about as equals z course is just a very
small part of the book it's full of all
sorts of cool stuff and i've put a link
under this video if you want to check
that out
also that graph i talked about that dave
put together where we've had a look at
sequels you can find that on my blog
again links underneath and if you want
to see even more from this video where i
asked rob even more questions stuff that
i've left out of this video for time
reasons i've put some of those extra
questions and answers as an unlisted
number file video and there'll be links
on the screen and underneath as well so
if you're really into this and you want
to hear rob talk about it more because
he's got a lot to say about it go check
that out